Instagram, in some ways, was an improbable success.
You look at my cofounder and I, and we'd never done a company before.
We were first time entrepreneurs.
We were telling people about what we're working on, and they're like,...
..."No, people have done photo apps before, this is never gonna work."
We showed it to some investors, and they're like, "I'm not interested in photos.
That's kind of been done before, you're gonna fail...
...especially public photos, people aren't gonna like that."
So it's really satisfying and great to launch and...
...actually have this community response of people being like,...
..."No, no, this is good...
...and it actually fills a need that I really had in my life."
Hearing "no" a lot of times usually tells you either you're crazy...
...or you're on the right track and you don't know which one it is until you finally launch.